my script did I take my pills artificial
intelligence voice cloning can create
highly realistic spoof videos and 54321
action or recreate the voice of long
dead artist Andy Warhol for a television
documentary I went down to the office
because they're making a robot of me
Silicon Valley startup resemble AI did
the Warhol voice cloning and has
projects in the works for several Global
entertainment companies it's not like a
technology that's imitating a voice but
it's using the voice itself
to to to speak exactly it's using the
voice data itself which is what the AI
model learned from and then it uses that
data to learn patterns of that voice and
be able to reproduce that to show us how
it works CEO zohab Ahmed had me record a
few phrases she told herself that after
all her fear had done no harm
after a few minutes of processing my
cloned voice recited a 19th century poem
on the sand half sunk a shattered Visage
lies who's frowned it'll be like
extremely realistic to the point that
the other person wouldn't be able to
recognize if it's if it's you or an
artificial voice resemble AI says it has
strict safeguards requires informed
consent from speakers and has a digital
watermark on its products for
verification rapid advances in voice
cloning technology carry with them risks
as well as opportunities and raise
questions about the nature of Truth
itself Rogue programmers could misuse
the technology to disastrous effect so
now imagine uh you're a 14 year old and
you've made some Tick Tock videos
in which you've talked and somebody goes
and grabs those video and clones your
voice and then calls your parents and
says I have your daughter
send me a hundred thousand dollars or
we're going to kill her and this is not
hypothetical in fact it happened last
week Bad actors could Target elections
governments or big corporations take
your favorite CEO and I'm going to
create a fake audio of them saying that
their profits are down 20 and I'm going
to leak it on Twitter and Twitter's
algorithms are going to amplify it how
long before I can move the market to the
tune of billions of dollars before
anybody figures out what's going on my
name is Ozymandias King of Kings experts
and Business Leaders are calling on
governments to come up with regulations
and safeguards and quickly to prevent
this form of AI technology from getting
out of control look on my Works ye
Mighty and despair Rob Reynolds Al
Jazeera Santa Clara California